so our next speaker is a Joel guess cone
he's the CEO and Founder a buffer which
is I'm sure you guys have all seen this
if you have twitter or facebook it's
where you see the b.f.f ly on your feed
but right now they have 26 employees
they do about 3.5 million dollars in
revenue and joel's talk is going to
cover how he was able to start buffer
and the most getaway possible so please
welcome Joel hi everyone it's great to
be here excited to chat with your so
yeah at some mention my name is Joel gas
going I'm the co-founder and CEO of a
company called buffer and today I want
to chat with you about some of the
tactics and lessons that we've learned
in the last few years that have helped
us to to grow buffer and so hopefully
this will be useful for you if you're
thinking about doing a start-up or if
you're working at a start-up right now
as a little bit about me I'm originally
from the UK and started buffer in the UK
about about four years ago almost now so
the end of 2010 and yeah I'm probably an
unusual choice of speaker for this
conference because I've actually been
coding since i was about 12 years old so
but at the same time i'm really excited
to speak with you and because of that
because i found that often coding was
kind of like a crutch for me and it was
kind of the first thing i would reach
for whenever had ideas and over time I
discovered that that's been a kind of a
really big mistake that I made and it's
something that I've had to adjust so
I've got a few different stories i want
to share with you of times where we've
kind of jump too quickly to coding and
it's kind of not worked out and then
i've got a few other stories where we've
had a lot of success without coding at
all our vision for the product is to be
the simplest and most powerful social
media tool and the problem we help to
solve is with posting to Facebook and
Twitter and scheduling posts so um the
idea is we give you a cue and you can
add content to that Q and then we'll
then space that content
for you over the course of the day so
you could read the news in the morning
and will then share that for you
throughout the whole day before I dive
in I also wanted to just mention three
kind of interesting things about the
company and that make us a little bit
different than other startups the first
one is that we have a fully distributed
team we're 26 people right now spread
all across the world we're in 20 cities
in five different continents the second
one is that we've raised 450 k seed
round of funding but we've hit
profitability based on that and so we've
not waste any more funding after that
and right now we don't have any plans to
raise more funding the third one is that
we have a core value of transparency
within the company and so we try and do
things in a very open way and this is
exciting because I think by sharing our
failures and successes we can really
help a lot of people and do things like
this so one of the most controversial
things that we've been transparent about
that you might have come across is we we
are completely transparent about
salaries and equity within the company
so we have a formula to determine the
salary of everyone in the company and we
make that formula public but not only
that but we have a list of everyone in
the company and their salary and that's
public too so this is all available just
at a Google spreadsheet and if you want
to check it out you can go to buff lee /
open pay cool and so before buffer I
worked on a previous start up for about
a year and a half and ultimately it was
failure but I learned a lot of lessons
along the way that contributed to how I
thought about starting off buffer I
think the two big mistakes i wanted to
mention the first one is that I just
built whatever came to my mind and and
without validating it and the second one
was that I didn't make enough effort to
talk with people about what I was
building and I think overall the big
mistake was that I just enjoyed the
coding too much and didn't and I kind of
forgot about building a business during
that time I
discovered the Lean Startup concepts and
our grease and I think that really
changed my mindset in love ways changed
how I thought about approaching ideas
and in a way that kind of changed my
life because it then changed a lot of
things about how I built things so kind
of based on the Lean Startup techniques
that I came across i decided with buffer
i wanted to take a different path and so
the funny thing is that as soon as i had
the idea for buffer I the first thing I
did was just to think about coding just
jump in and and then I kind of had to
just stop myself and say you know what
should I how should I approach this in a
lean way and how can i validate this
without going ahead and building the
whole product and so I think that's
probably one of the big lessons that
I've learned after a few different
failures is that um I think if I look
back now it's clear that I was building
things as a hobby really and I think
that's what happens when you just go and
build whatever comes to mind and that
can be fun but i think you know if you
really want to build a business you need
to validate your ideas either that
you've just got to get really lucky so
thinking about how to approach things in
a lean way and I thought how can i
validate the idea of buffer before I
even built a product and so this is what
I came up with and it's a simple three
page website and other time I built this
myself but there's lots of tools out
there right now that are much better
equipped to building like this than
diving into code so something like bond
bounce would be absolutely perfect for
building this and yeah so I kind of just
to walk through this the most important
thing to notice about this free page
website is that the first page made it
look like the product already existed
and I think that was really important if
you wanted to get a ton of signups it
might not be the best thing to do but if
you want to truly validate whether you
people want your idea and I think it's
kind of crucial so the first page was
just like a landing page it had a
headline and then three steps
and then it had a plans and pricing
button and then they would click the
place the plans and pricing button and
go to the next page which was just a
pricing page and then from there they
would choose one of the plans and then
they would end up on the final page and
the final page and just says hello
you've called us too soon we're not
quite ready yet and then it would give
them a chance to put the email inbox and
give me their email and be notified when
the products actually existed so I drove
a bit of traffic to this free page
website and luckily some people went all
the way through and gave me their email
at the end so that was pretty great and
as you already know I was kind of
obsessed with the Lean Startup so I was
pretty excited about looking at the
analytics and checking the funnel and
looking all the numbers and things and
that was another big lesson that I
learned is that in the early days the
numbers are just not that useful you
just don't have the volume really am but
instead what was useful and what I did
was that every person that gave me the
email i personally emailed them and got
into it and then i had a conversation
with them so i had a lot of
conversations over email and had a few
skype calls as well and what I found was
that once people understood understood
the concept and quite a few of them said
that they would want to use this product
and a few even said that they would pay
for it if it existed and at the same
time quite a few people told me that I
was crazy and the no one would ever use
this and no one will pay for it and but
I was pretty happy that I actually had
some validation from a few people that
said that they would want to use it so
that gave me kind of enough confidence
to go ahead and think about building the
first kind of minimal version of the
actual product
cool so I'd kind of decided to build the
first version of the product and that
was when I reflected on the Lean Startup
concepts again and something that Eric
we said really kind of stood out in my
mind one of his conferences one of his
presentations someone asked this in the
Q&A session they said how many more
should your Minimum Viable Product be
your first version of you product and
Eric we said that there's probably not
there's not like a perfect answer but
the answer is almost always that it
should probably be much more minimal
than you think and so I really tried to
keep this in mind when I approached
building the first version of buffer so
the first thing that I approached in
kind of a minimal way was the actual
feature set itself so the first version
of buffer and you could only use it for
Twitter so there was no other networks
you could use it for not only that we
could only use it for one Twitter
account and there was no analytics
either so really was purely just this
idea of the queue for one Twitter
account and that was it um and I think
that's kind of an important point is
that when you're doing your first
version I think it's useful to be kind
of laser focused with what you put out
there and so I think it helps you then
when you put it out there that it's
going to be a very clear signal one way
or the other hi there works or it
doesn't whereas if you have a bunch of
features it's going to be much more
cloudy and you're not going to know what
folks on what to improve and a couple of
other things that we left out in this
first version the first was the actual
or grade process of going from the free
version to the paid version and so
normally when you pay for a product that
you expect that you would you put your
card details in and you then you kind of
get an email pub Lee and you get access
to these paid features right away way
and what happened with the first couple
of months of buffer was that you would
pay with paypal and then I would get an
email into my personal inbox that said
someone had paid with paypal and then I
would rush to the database and upgrade
them manually and then email them the
welcome email personally and I
apologize for the delay of our systems
and and this kind of worked out really
well because I mean maybe it wasn't an
ideal experience for the user but what
happened then was that I had a lot of
conversations with users and then it
actually became an even better
experience for them another example was
that on the paid version there was a
paid feature of using your own custom
bit ly details and that was another
thing where the way I thought about it
was it's on the paid version but it
doesn't really have validation yet and
it didn't make sense for me to build
that out before had any paying customers
why would have work on a paid feature
when I could instead work on trying to
get that first paying customer and in
the first place so there was this
feature to have your own custom bit ly
details which would let you then see the
cliq analytics in your in your bit ly
dashboard but um so this didn't exist
and then so the first couple of people
that are graded it actually wasn't a
problem because they purely upgraded to
get more space in that buffer and but
the third person that upgraded sent me
an email and said doesn't seem like this
is working and so I said okay I'll just
I'll look into it and then I thought
that's probably a good time for me to
actually build this feature and so yeah
and then it took me about a couple of
hours and then I've applied back and
said you know maybe you can try it now
and I think it's I think it's fixed now
and and so then he was really happy with
it and again I got to have a
conversation and learn more about what
other things he would want as well and
so the end result of the kind of landing
page experiment and the minimal first
version was pretty great and it was a
seven-week process in total from having
the idea to launching the first version
and had we had the first paying customer
after four days so it worked how well it
was just a five dollar payment it took a
while I was still working full time
doing web development on the side so it
took a while to be able to drop that and
focus full-time but it was a whole new
experience for me yeah so we we kind of
start
off well but and what happened then over
the next like you or two is that we
struggle to approach everything with
that same kind of discipline and a few
weeks ago we look to have heat and
showers a advisor he's going to be
speaking a little bit later and he said
to us that he sees a strange thing with
startups they'll do customer development
once but then they'll fail to make it
part of the product process and this is
something that we found to be really
true and that's something we struggle
with a lot so I've got a couple more
examples I want to share with you of one
where we've failed and then another one
where we kind of succeeded cool so
here's the first one and this is our
browser extension pop-up so we have
browser extensions for chrome firefox
and safari and almost forty percent of
all the sharing that happens comes from
a browser extension so it's been a huge
part of our of our success and back in
2012 we started to notice an interesting
thing going on with facebook at the time
which was that pictures were becoming a
lot more prevalent on social media and
today they're really be part of Twitter
as well so they kind of become a big
deal back then we noticed it and so we
tried it out in our own accounts and we
saw a lot of engagement so we were
excited to try and help our users with
this as well and and get a lot of
engagement by using pictures we also
were quite inspired by things like
Pinterest where they'll show you all the
pictures on the page and let you pin
pictures so we thought we could do
something like that so we kind of
decided that we wanted to enhance the
browser extension and bring in this
picture sharing kind of ability into it
so we got to work and a couple of months
later we came up with this so you can
see there's like four tabs on the left
hand side so we would let you choose
between sharing a link a picture a video
or just a status update and that's how
it looks after sharing a picture and so
we were pretty excited this we started
using it ourselves and it was working
really well for us we got a lot more
engagement by using pictures and then we
kind of we were so excited that we
nearly rolled it
out to the whole user base and then I
think one of us in the team just said
well maybe we should let a few users try
this first and see what they think so we
decided to do some user testing and my
co-founder Leo just jumped on he
actually jumped on seven skype calls
with customers and we just enabled it
for them and ask them to talk us through
how how I felt and what they were and
what they thought things meant and stuff
like that the results were pretty
shocking we discovered that six out of
seven people were completely confused
with the UI and and so we discovered
that people thought that the picture
here was like the link attachment that
would come up in facebook for when
you're showing a link and people just
didn't get it at all and we discovered
that our team was completely biased like
we knew exactly how it worked because we
knew the problem we were solving from
the first place so we knew exactly what
the you I meant and stuff so that was
kind of a big shame and especially
because we could have known this exact
same learning just by doing user testing
with mock-ups two months earlier the
final story I want to share with you
guys this afternoon is how buffer for
business came about so buffer for
business is a paid plans beyond the most
popular ten dollars a month plan for
buffer so we have fifty dollars a month
hundred dollars month and two hundred
fifty dollars a month let me have a few
enterprise customers beyond that and
it's only been available for just over
six months but it's already become a
pretty big success and it's at
twenty-seven percent of our monthly
revenue now and so yeah so the first
thing for us to kind of decide with
buffer business was what would the
products even be and so we had a couple
of different ideas in mind when we
thought about before business we had
either just purely extending what
already existed so people could have
more accounts more team members and
share more content the other one was
something we were really excited about
was a brand-new product and the idea was
to help companies to make use of all
employees if they connect that
an old Twitter and Facebook accounts and
have them share the news from the
company of the press releases or job
listings and things like that so we
thought this would be really great for
marketing departments for companies so
what we did was we spoke with quite a
few different customers so my co-founder
leo he did a lot of customer development
and what we found was the thing that we
were really excited about and just ended
up not resonating at all with people
when we spoke with them so I think the
best the best thing we the most useful
thing we heard was a head of marketing
said I can't rely on my camera I on the
team to do marketing like that's what we
have to do and so this will be a nice to
have but we will wouldn't pay for this
alone and where was the extending buffer
and having more functionality and that
was something that like really resonated
and people were super excited about so
and we had a lot of people that were
hitting the limits of the ten dollars a
month account and so there was a lot of
kind of pent up demand there so we knew
which one we needed to minions build and
so I just want to walk you through then
the process we went through kind of
after that so we try to think about how
can we validate this further and kind of
build this out in a really lean way and
what we realized is that if we just go
and stripe we can add more plans in
there so we added just a bunch of plans
for different price points and we then
Leo would just talk with customers who
were hitting those limits and asked them
if they wanted to get on to buffer for
business which all it was really was
releasing those limits and quite a few
people wanted that so then he would just
move them onto the plan in stripe and
then we would start charging them more
so this was great and in a very short
space of time we had our first ten
thousand dollars in revenue and that was
six percent of our revenue at the time
so it was pretty huge right away we then
thought how can we get more leads so
what we decided to do was to set up a
woo foo form and just asking for the
email and phone number if they want to
get more information about before
business
and so we advertise this in Twitter and
on the blog and that helps us grow the
revenue even more then we realized that
we could we could drive more leads if we
put just a little bit of doing a tiny
bit of code and put something on the
pricing page at the bottom and so just
letting people go to that woohoo form
the next thing we did was to we thought
it might be good to better qualify the
leads and that helped Leo a lot so we
added a bunch more fields to the roof
reform and yeah then finally um by that
time it was kind of a month or two after
we'd started and we'd learned a lot and
the pricing points became kind of clear
so we decided to do a pricing page but
we still didn't do it ourselves and
write any code or anything we just
decided to use wufu so we had this
woohoo page with the pricing plans and
we couldn't connect it to our database
so we had to like ask for the email
again and stuff but it worked really
well and it helps us to be able to test
different prices and things like that so
this was great and yeah so today buffer
for business is one of the best things
we've done in the last year and it's
twenty-seven percent of our Avenue now
and it's almost 100k a month in revenue
that we're getting from buffer business
so that's yeah that's all the stories i
want to share with you guys one quick
thing to refer back to the middle of the
talk on how we're trying to make this a
process now so we're we have Heaton
mentioned towards these four steps and
in the last few weeks we've been really
trying to vigorously follow these steps
and especially kind of making these
steps required for every thing that we
do is what's helping a lot especially
the hypothesis part is where we actually
need to talk with people so cool that's
everything and thanks so much for
listening and loved answer any questions
you have
I think we can take two questions hey
there how are you hey Michael from lots
of stops great talk if you wouldn't mind
so you have your team is is all over the
world right yeah so that's what I'm
looking to do as I built my company and
I'm curious if you might want to briefly
talk about the pros and cons of having a
team that's dispersed worldwide yeah
absolutely that's a written question so
I think there's some huge benefits that
we've found we were we were hacked last
year and it was pretty crazy was a tough
situation but the fact that the team was
fully distributed across the world been
though we didn't have to do a crazy I
know two or three days staying up all
night just to resolve that and we can
have the different people in the world
jumping under different points so it's
been really really great I think the one
key thing I would say with a distributed
team is I got some advice from a guy
called David cancel he's done quite a
few startups and he's the product chief
product officer for hope spot by now and
he said to me he's had a few startups
and he's tried both ways he said what
you want to do is have either everyone
in a inner office or have everyone
distributed and if you go half way it's
going to be really tough because then
you end up with like second-class
citizens and I know communication
happening in the office that other
people don't know about so that's how we
do things we have an office in San
Francisco but we just have four or five
people in there and we still use hipchat
a lot and we kind of say that HipChat is
our office so yeah that's probably I
would say but yeah we can catch up
afterwards if you have any more
questions as well
hey I think it's really cool you're into
the Lean Startup I work for the
publisher that actually publishes the
lean series and we want to use buffer
for business right now so we're very
excited about that listen I'm interested
in validation did you ever try to
validate something I'm failed was there
ever an idea that didn't validate that
you considered and didn't go through
with yeah i mean the so the browser
extension was a key one that failed and
another one was and I think that's play
the best example there is one that we
didn't validate and it went through and
then we found out a few months later so
we did a whole redesign of the buffer
dashboard and we we didn't validate it
at all and then when we didn't look at
any numbers or anything we didn't a be
test it nothing so then two months or
three months after we launched it we
started to get really focused on data
and look at numbers and things we
managed to trace back that we had a huge
drop in activation and of new users so
the new dashboard was converting a new
users to active users much worse than
before and that's something that we've
actually been kind of catching up with
ever since so oh sure thanks sure cool